[Music]
in breakup exam news Oh No submitted by
Kenya's can you see you later
a Chinese Court has launched the divorce
exam that couples must fail in order to
end their marriage cool come Chinese has
to make everything I could that's genius
Li failed Asian people are programmed to
not want to fail because then you bring
shame to the family divorce good job for
the divorce doesn't bring shame to the
family just just the failure of the test
I rather have your divorce then gonna
yeah so this video is brought to you by
east meet east have you guys heard of
this app yes it's a dating app yeah you
don't have to be Asian to be a part of
the app though oh yeah there's there's
non-asians on it too oh yeah but it's
it's you know you know I guess it's for
Asians that can't find other Asians or
whatever yeah oh yeah there's some big
cities you trying to meet some Asians
and then you're like what all the Asians
at and now instead of going to that one
club that used to be a Chinese
restaurant during the day you could find
on an app or if you're like living here
and you want a traditional meet a
traditional guy or girl back in your
parents hometown or whatever they have
or you can go out and find it from
another city yeah well now it's just
more convenient because I think that's
just how we all operate like on social
media like I know none of our friends
that have met like online so it's just
gonna be neat to me yeah but yeah you
so yes having a nap and then just
scrolling through you know whatever like
the people that have the same interests
as you or you can already see the
picture you're like oh she's hot or he's
hot like those are cool because you
could search people by like their income
or where they know and then also you
could search the age that they arrive to
the US - can you search by source by GPA
- how many AP classes have you taken I
wouldn't mind the Inc know it kind of
cool if you could search by GPA profile
on the app so here we have Chris he
arrived to the US and you know 1790 was
17 years old gonna give Chris some
advice
so Chris if you want to get a lot of
girls that's a horrible picture you look
like the handsome dude but there's like
shadow on your face you're wearing
glasses you can't even see your facial
features you're always take a picture
with the son they see you not your back
because you want the Sun to accentuate
your beautiful face many of us see there
or if you're a busted dude then you
always want to wear a hat and that'll
make your face look better the next guy
has a hand obviously he's in a beautiful
paradise for some reason oceans and
beaches make people look ten times
better and it's smart that he did that
cuz now it just shows that he has money
to travel good call um yeah what about
this that's bad that's bad man she looks
like a cute girl but like why in the
dark is so dark yeah you got any more
you gotta let your beauty out girl
come on I go how about this one might as
well be can
[Laughter]
yeah just take off that hood take off
those glasses let the Sun come and make
your skin glow yeah don't be shy a lens
flare do they can you upload multiple me
wait wait wait go back
how much money does he make less than
50k no no he's going to medical school
though he has he's going something like
those stats it's like a type of baseball
players that it's his drink socially
right so is there option for alcoholic
uncontrollably it's a prerequisite yeah
we have a knee here that's a cute
picture it's slightly overexposed try to
take the most natural pictures you can
yeah yeah there's no foreheads true we
should look sweet like a cute girl yeah
she might have had to take that picture
inside like a coffee shop where there's
a bunch of people if she didn't want the
background in so it was like Oh true
yeah if you guys want to check out east
meets East make sure to check out the
link in the description box below so now
on to the story so the Chinese Court did
introduce this exam to couples that want
to get divorced
there was this first couple that
attempted it and they passed the exam so
they were denied you see that's
something don't worry
Chinese people a program to want to pass
pass what are some of the sample
question oh like what's on this test oh
do they know that they're supposed to
fail in order to get the okay yeah you
know they're supposed to fail they have
to get it could be reverse psychology
questions I'm sure you know psychology
or personality tests they they make the
questions like you by you trying to game
the system they actually figure out who
you really are so it's never those
surface-level type things it's probably
multiple questions of the same thing but
we're reworded so that it tricks their
mind like when you apply for like a
police department they go alright have
you taken any illegal substance and then
and then and then you'd be like oh no
and it'll tell you well this is the time
where you can tell them because if you
tell me and I clear you
here we can sign a waiver and then your
that's gonna be completely removed from
your background information we can move
forward and so a lot of people they feel
really comfortable at that point and
they all right well so I did smoke they
got you so the surface-level question is
to game you maybe what they did was they
use the questions to game the person
they did mention that you have to have a
60% or less in order to get a divorce
89% of lower I think I know I think I
know why they're doing this because
sometimes you need a mediator when
you're like fighting and then you think
you're so sure of the divorce right but
then like the test is actually to make
sure if you really want to do this or
not and then they take the test and then
they're like does he beat you no you
know does he run off and gamble all the
money away
no think that's it and you're like
[Laughter]
sometimes I get so worried about him not
putting the toilet seat down you know
but [ __ ] yeah it's not a matchmaker to
stay together I think so like it's like
a questionnaire like you know how bad is
it
yeah so the exam is divided into three
parts
it's a fill in the blanks short answer
and statement [ __ ] that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
as a mother like a GED
some of the questions that they say they
ask is like the spouses favorite food
the spouses parents birthdays or things
like that so shallow ball because you
know too much about each other you guys
are meant to be yes
no no divorce keep fighting no divorce
work it out there's one couple that took
the exam the wife the husband got 80%
and the wife got 86% so then the judge
was just saying like you know
you're doing pretty good then yeah they
can make it like this examines to see
like whether if you get 60 or below it's
like your relationship is just there's
no way you're gonna fix it might as well
get divorced that that is what it is
right yeah so then she said for this
specific couple it seemed like the
husband was addicted to gambling and
rude to his spouse and then he also
showed lack of responsibility to his
family but he still passed yeah they
still passed cuz we got 80% it's a one
minor problem compared to the world of
positivity six percent does he gamble
yes
come on what Chinese dump the Ambo I
could try it in a past life in Chinese
it's also it's also like simplified you
might have simplified over there's I
don't know you know Tricia knows way
more hardcore you're not know the
simplified is harder because it's a new
it's a new language so I got my never
learn that stuff need something
something something something change our
anniversary what is your anniversary
date neither something something center
that's birthday hides the sin which
means your kids birthday
neither some Oh what do you like to hear
yeah she when what is your kid like to
eat hey
Oh someone he says what is your kid like
tea and hero fruits and it says I'm
gonna read that [ __ ] yeah I don't
read that [ __ ] each other and smooch
is something a whole [ __ ] is it uh how
many trips have you guys how many family
trips have you guys been on he put four
and he says I haven't been on any Mayo
like yeah like a read yeah there was
another so basic questions if you don't
pass that your piece of [ __ ] only one
page though I could it might be the
beginning like hi wait but on the
brighter note he might gamble away the
family fortune but he won't forget your
birthday and that's important
you give you keep the kids for with
prefer only healthy yeah well the deputy
director of the National Lawyers
Committee said that the design of the
test needs to have like a scientific
basis but they should have they should
find like a psychologist or sociology I
work till I join T actually work on this
exam to see if it's even worth taking
really give it's even effective at all
that's so funny that would that should
be the first thing that they do court
committee going what should we do you
should know each other's birthdays
what's the point of this like why did
they feel they had to implement it all
of us think they're trying to decrease
their the doors yeah they're just trying
to see like if their marriage can even
be worked on at all and I guess this is
the way that this specific I think just
asking like socially like across the
nation is there a really high divorce
rate sure they're trying to lower the
divorcement
it's the reason to even start this whole
thing well this was just administered by
by one particular court it's not
something that's like nation away well
it's not like a Chinese Supreme Court no
mmm you know what would be funny of
those if they started like getting out
this test like random people on the
street like random couples instead well
you just take this blood test you know
you see what do like scores they go yeah
I don't know I kind of like the idea but
divorce test right yeah I think it's
very difficult to kind of get married it
should be just as difficult to get
divorced it's very I know there should
be a divorce boot camp do you really
want to leave each other yeah especially
if you have kids yeah some people I
think like just with the divorce rate
going higher and higher I feel like
people they treat it as if they're just
breaking up look like a junior high
crush usually make it really hard and
then they get married again and then
they get divorced again for the same
reason they got divorced before so they
need to work on themselves and they just
don't get it
the same problems with everyone else
yeah it's like before there was social
stigma but now you know since it's so
common there's no social stigma right so
there's nothing really people preventing
people from getting divorced and then
for all the people that are like well
what if she's getting beat up and like
what if what if she's an alcoholic and
all that stuff it's like yeah those
things do happen but that's not why
people get divorced in the first place
it's because they're not in love anymore
or it's because they fight too much and
they can't deal with it and it's usually
problems that can be solved if you work
work at it and it's it's a really you
know it's a way smaller case that it's
like abuse or something in those cases
of course you should run away but if you
was you know people don't start beating
you up like thirty years into the
relationship that [ __ ] usually happens
like when you're a couple
you're like red flag yeah there's red
flags you know so I don't know man I
don't like it I've also seen Asian
couples fall back in love after 30 years
they fall in love they get together and
then you know like almost every single
Asian mom and dad day you start sitting
on opposite sides of the couch dad read
a newspaper mom's on the floor cutting
durian and they don't talk for like like
30 years and then like that and it's
almost like they're like divorced but
living in the same house and then
magically when their grandparents again
they start [ __ ] again like that's how
they started so they will focus so much
mmm because the emigrated here so they
focus so much on just getting their
career started getting like a solid
foothold on like just the American Way
and then they got together got kids
that's not least we couldn't focus on
their relationship so they focus on the
kids and then once the kids move out
then it's like oh [ __ ]
has arose in his mouth yeah and my mom
was like dude like you rekindled like
like this is like the best relationship
who ever had like once we all laughter
well no because that my life is
completely different than theirs because
they they came here highschool years so
then they just hustled and then jumped
into a related travel didn't do any of
that stuff and it wasn't until we left
that they were like now what do we do a
retired like it's traveling this little
Grand Canyon's go to Joshua Tree of we
have a [ __ ] that goes there many thanks
for watching guys and those are our
thoughts what are your thoughts don't
forget to comment below we want to know
what you guys are thinking but don't
write anything that will make it sad or
make us mad because after all we're just
kidding news and we're a very happy
channel for the last video click up here
[Music]